looming taller and taller over british
politics is the discussion going on in
these houses
in this neighborhood which will choose
its next mp
next week join us at really harder polar
towers
some courts from sky news of course a
deputy political editor and chris lloyd
from the north neck
after covid and brexit could the first
chapter of the story of labour's revival
begin here the harley pool is a unique
sort of a place
69 and a half percent brexit to leave
one of the highest areas in the country
yet at the 2019 general election it
didn't
fall from labour to the conservatives
and it really should have done there was
a kind of tidal wave
of uh tourism that swept down the teas
valley
a tide that may be stopped by a labour
campaign fronted by a doctor
who has been making a virtue of the fat
labor is still under comparatively new
management
shakir would done really well when he
when he visited here i think people
people people don't know him that well
um he
and over the last year with with covert
it's been difficult for him to
um to be able to travel to places like
this i think this by-election is a
is a real opportunity for keir to to
show who he really is
that means being heard above the noise
given that this seat has never had
anyone other than a labour mp
it should be theirs to lose but
the pattern of recent elections around
here hasn't been good for them
and privately labor admit that kier
starmet just
isn't as big a figure as boris johnson
and then all sides in this by-election
are talking about the vast
sums being put into this region by the
tory government
we want something we want something to
alive and hardly pull bring hartley
pulled back
to where it was years and years ago well
there's absolutely no doubt about which
we are voting
conservative i think if we get in if
we've got a conservative government
sorry a conservative mp in this town
they will want to try and keep that
conservative mp and they will
start to spend money
i think it will be a very tough fight
but i've been talking to people on the
doors this week
and they are ready for positive change
and the sport's been great but i need
absolutely everybody who wants that
change to come out and vote
opponents are making the case they could
all secure the cash hartlepool needs
they need someone who can grasp that
opportunity
and get hartlepool moving forwards get
the reco get the economy reopened again
rebuilt make sure that hartlepool gets
its fair share of investment
investment is coming but look how it's
being divided up
seven towns have been selected for
funding since november
as part of boris johnson's 3.6 billion
pound leveling up fund
five towns are in seats with tory mps
while just two
are in areas with a labour mp some like
hartlepool haven't got the promise money
yet
so that's going to be a new 90 million
pounds key
half an hour down the road in newly tory
red car emp
can point to projects that got
government cash
for years we saw our investment directed
at our cities
and we we saw our cities grow and grow
and our towns feel left
behind and places like redcar they need
the investment
but the opposition say funding is a
smokescreen
i certainly think it is what's called
pork barrel politics they're putting
money into areas where they've won seats
they're shoring up their support we all
want the leveling up agenda to succeed
i want money for my patch hartlepudlians
still
feel left behind the winner will be the
person who can convince voters they have
more to offer
sam coats sky news hartlepool